[MUSIC PLAYING]
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 147 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Melanie Warrick,
and I'm here
with special co-hosts, Willie
Brink and Nyalleng Moorosi.
Hello, Willie.
Hello, Nyalleng.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Hi, Melanie.
WILLIE BRINK: Hi.
NYALLENG MOOROSI:
It's good to be here.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you for being here.
All right.
I'm going to have you
both take a quick minute
and tell us a little
bit about who you are.
WILLIE BRINK: Thanks.
I'm Willie.
I am a lecturer at
Stellenbosch University.
This is, of course,
also the hosts
for this year's Deep
Learning Indaba.
I have a passion for machine
learning, computer vision.
I have a passion for teaching,
and it is wonderful for me
to be here.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
glad you're here.
Nyalleng?
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Yeah.
I'm Nyalleng Moorosi, as
Melanie has mentioned.
I recently joined
the Google AI team
for the group that's
going to be play-- that's
going to be in Accra, Ghana.
I'm very excited about that.
Before that, I was a researcher
at the Council for Scientific
and Industrial Research--
it's a very, very long name.
But it's a research lab here
in South Africa, government
funded, and also
partially industry.
I'm very, very excited to
be going to Accra because I
can continue doing
machine learning
and continue living in Africa,
which is exactly why we
are here at the Indaba.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
We are doing this recording,
and this episode specifically
is about Deep
Learning Indaba, where
we're going to showcase
a couple of interviews
that we captured
during this week.
Can you both take a
minute and just tell
the audience what Deep
Learning Indaba is about?
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Our line is
strengthening African machine
learning, so it's always
good to start with that.
But I think the Deep Learning
Indaba has become strengthening
African machine learning, but
I think when we started it,
we did not know exactly
how much it would.
And it has become a community
of sharing knowledge,
of sharing skill, of
celebrating one another,
and of course,
continual learning.
So it almost feels
like it's going
to be our yearly
pilgrimage, where
from wherever we come from, we
go to wherever everybody is,
and we collaborate,
and we work together,
and we just, we catch
up and we celebrate
what we did with the last year.
WILLIE BRINK: Yeah.
And I think also what
is very important
for us is to equip students and
academics from all over Africa
to come together, to meet each
other, to network, but very
importantly also, to go back
to their own communities
and carry on this message of
strengthening machine learning,
and really just catching up
with the rest of the world.
Africa has enormous
potential, and I
think it's a very exciting
time for all of us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
Well as I mentioned, we
have some interviews.
In this episode,
in particular, we
are going to be talking
with-- and Willie,
you helped me with this--
we're talking with Yasin
and we are also
talking with Vukosi,
and we're going to spend part
of that interview really talking
a little bit more about what
Deep Learning Indaba is about
and some of the awards
that were given out.
And then the other part of
our interview that was covered
was with Andrea, who's
a VC here in Africa.
And I know Nyalleng and
I just spoke with her
and had a great conversation.
So before we get
into our interviews,
as always, we
start out with some
of the cool things of the week
and a question of the week.
And we're going to wrap up with
a question that is pretty much,
what are some of our key
takeaways from the conference.
But as I mentioned,
we'd like to start out
with the cool thing
of the week, and we're
going to do a
little variation off
of this, which is to help
talk a little bit about,
what are some of the highlights
that have been going on--
not the key takeaways, but
things that have been happening
during this conference.
What are some of the great
things that have been going on
or activities?
Like I know that we've had a
lot of speakers here, and--
WILLIE BRINK: Yeah.
So we've really had
an action-packed week.
Great speakers, Nando
de Freitas was here,
and Moustapha Cisse, and
lots of others, David Silver,
Jeff Dean.
So it's a really, really
great list of speakers.
We also had poster sessions,
which were amazing,
all the students
presenting their own work,
movie screenings of AlphaGo.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
WILLIE BRINK: There was a
Woman in Machine Learning
event one evening, which
was really inspiring.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nyalleng,
you were speaking at that one
as well.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Yeah.
And it was very well attended.
It was one of our
biggest sessions.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And then there's
been students who are from
all over different countries
within Africa.
My understanding is
like 30 countries.
And the number of attendees
is around 550 attendees?
WILLIE BRINK: That's right.
MELANIE WARRICK: Outside
of the WIML event,
I think one of the
cool things that I
saw was when David
Silver walked in
and somebody was sitting there
and looked over and saw him.
It was like, oh my god, I
just saw you in a movie.
He was so excited.
I thought that was
pretty fun to watch.
Any other little highlights
that come to mind?
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Yeah.
I think I also saw somebody
on a David Silver spotting.
He kind of lost his
mind a little bit.
The cool events, oh goodness.
There are just so many.
My coolest event was
the awards sessions,
and the posters
are always really
rewarding and enlightening,
and half the time
you just go there to
just learn, meeting
all the other people that are
actually machining learning.
And maybe that's
actually something
to mention about the number
of people that have traveled
from far, other researchers
that have jam-packed
a schedule, that traveled
from far to come spend
the week with us.
And that's been very
exciting to see them also.
MELANIE WARRICK: I agree.
Very much so.
Any posters that jump out?
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Oh.
Well, this is really
putting me on the spot
because the one poster that
I do remember was actually
Steve Kroon and Herman.
Herman is also a colleague
who organized this.
And this poster will be at
NIPS, this year's NIPS poster.
And they have a
closure, they have
discovered about how to
add noise in a network.
So how much noise can
you add in a network
until you can't learn any more?
So actually, you
saturate the network,
and you cannot anymore
learn in a deep net.
And so they have these
closure properties
about how deep you can go, and
how much noise you can add,
and that's really
beautiful because so much--
I mean, that just narrows the
parameter tuning search space.
This is work that's being done
right here in Stellenbosch.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Well, I think it's time
for us to go ahead and jump
into our interviews.
So let's go do that.
Today, I'm excited to have
with me Dr. Vukosi Marivate
and Yasin Musa Ayami, who are
both here at Deep Learning
Indaba, which is based in
Stellenbosch, South Africa,
for this edition of the
Deep Learning Indaba.
And with me also is Willie
Brink, who is helping
to be my special guest co-host.
So thank you all
for coming today.
VUKOSI MARIVATE: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Now let
me go ahead and kick us off
like we usually do, which
is to have you tell us
a little bit about who you are.
So Vukosi, can you start?
VUKOSI MARIVATE: Thank
you for having me over.
My background, mostly,
is in machine learning.
At the moment, I am the
chair of data science
and a senior lecturer at
the University of Pretoria.
Ticking through my
background, I was
interested in machine
and AI from a young age,
ended up going--